Byron how is life life is good can't
complain how you doing I'm doing okay
how blindsided did you feel getting
fired or how ever played out only blood
satisfied you know it was one of those
things it was unfortunate you know
especially for me you know I thought the
situation that we had talked about a few
years ago that they knew that the
situation basically will take a few
years and they're giving me the
knowledge that day we were with you with
entrepreneurial take you know two or
three years get this kind of turned
around so I was in there blindsided by
it but and I don't have me any will it
will feelings against the organization I
still love the lake organization and
wish them all the best but you had you
know these different kind of vantage
points of Kobe was going to go out
wanted to go out the way he wanted to go
out but then you're trying to develop
these young kids it's hard to do both
isn't it Myron is this job yeah it
looked out about it you know the
juggling act all season long you know
because she do have a bunch of young
guys that you're trying to develop and
get them understand how to play the
right way and these Geico views on
basically a tour playing his final
season so you know as I said you know
from day one you know my main objective
which AP was to make sure he finished
the season as healthy as possible so he
can play that last game and to perform
to our level I did I didn't know some
putrid scent high levels but you know
that was kind of my main objective so
yeah juggling at y'all off you logged in
and but the be honest with you i enjoyed
it I look the way we ended the station I
love the way the way I love the way Kobe
went out and I have fond memories of
that how would you sum up the last two
years rough very rough you know but
that's what I expect you know that
that's what I expected that to live when
I took the job but we sit down rich and
I gym that
the whole business of conversations that
these next two or three years ago be
pretty tough and can I handle the
situation and I tell you I could handle
it I knew I could handle it obtained to
come to work every single day was smile
on my face and very positive which is
just my nature anyway the cheap work and
that's what I continued to do can you
clear something up that Jeanie buss said
she didn't know that you were fired that
Jim Buss fired you is that how it played
out I have no idea I read that as well a
couple of months people came up to me
and said the same thing that Jim she
didn't have any idea about it so I had
no idea to be honest which all I know is
I went Richard ditch our capture call me
into the office and told me that there
wasn't going to extend my contract that
states to have played out all right as
the Lakers move forward now that you're
no longer the coach is D'Angelo Russell
the long term amenia star at that
position point guard I think he came in
you know it obviously there will be some
question marks with that it is work
after guys to get better as
understanding of gas to get that but he
hasn't told he can flat out scorer
really change the floor extremely well
so he has some tools that use that you
can't teach you know but the little
intricate parts of the game it's easier
to learn and he's 20 years old I mean
he's a young pup he's got a long ways to
go but if he puts into work I think the
kid could be a great player did you have
to give him tough love absolutely every
now and then you know I think somebody's
guys when they come into the lead they
think they're entitled and you know I
thought that's how he felt when he first
got with us you know he almost tried to
act like he was a veteran and I tried to
make sure that he wasn't make sure the
huger whether that you have to earn your
stripes well yeah there were times when
I was a little tough on him just just to
bring him back down to earth to let him
know that this is not an easy task when
you win the NBA no that's the easy part
is getting their hardest part of
standard getting better and better and
better so yeah I have some tough love
but a young man but you know just like I
told him but I stopped talking to you
oh well you know I had a lot of a lot of
long time and they put herself in some
tough situations obviously but I think
he'd go be a good player talking to
Byron Scott former Laker head coach
joining a Stan Patrick show if Luke
Walton asked for advice what would you
tell him well you know then that would
be between looking at out we can I would
be as honest with them as positive I me
as possible and if you ask me about each
and every one of the players are on the
team I would tell them I would give my
honest opinion about the guys for the
most part to be honest with you you're
the first thing I would tell them is it
you got a bunch of good guys and you got
a bunch of guys at warmth they want to
do the right things and just don't know
how so that's the one thing you got to
continue to teach them but I would be
very positive it was very obvious we
look about the situation you've been
around the game a long time you've seen
a lot of things where do you put Colby's
scoring 60 in his final game you know
what I think that will go down dead is
one of the best finishing acts to a
career in the history of basketball I
don't think we might not see that in our
lifetime where a player at 37 years old
players 20 years in the NBA his last
game he scored 62 points and retires I
don't think if you wrote a book about
Kobe's 20 years in the NBA and you had
that finish at the end of the last
chapter I don't think people would
believe it you know so it was it was a
dream to sit there and watch it you know
we have some conversations during the
game that I'll never forget and to go
out that way I think is a dream come
true and you know he laid it out on the
floor every night that's the one thing
you got to say about Kobe Bryant in 20
years you never left anything a chance
he went out there and played his heart
out every single night and that's that's
that's special right there can you share
any of the conversations you had during
that last game the 60-point performance
well you know then I'll share just one
real quick at the 930 the 930 mark I
think we're down in single digits and
you know we had a timeout and I drew up
a play and he was sitting there as you
could just see him his chance to just
move he's breathing pretty heavy
and I put my hands on his knees and I
said you got nine and a half minutes
left in that body of yours and he looked
at me he said absolutely it's a seven
minute mark the game is going on I
turned I look at our coaches I said he
is tired as can be the next time I was
at the five-minute mark and I looked at
him and I asked him the same questions
you got five minutes left in that body
of yours he looked me dead in the face
and he took a deep breath and he said
yeah so it wasn't it wasn't the absolute
feeling media has four minutes ago and
it just kind of cracked me up and I was
wondering at that time how was he going
to make this next five minutes through
this game but uh you know it sure will
is amazing and he was able to do it have
you interviewed for the coaching
vacancies certainly miss Sacramento is
there a possibility that you're going to
get a chance there maybe Houston you
know what I have not you know I took my
agent last week when this news came I
totally just relax I just wanted to just
take a week and just relax and chill out
and spend some time with my family and
my daughters and my son and my grandkids
and just relaxed so those are two
interesting jobs you know that the
Vantage of both you look at Sacramento
DeMarcus Cousins as a star only a
superstar you're probably the best thing
in our league right now along with
Marcus all that would be a great
opportunity I would love to interview
with them and the same with used to me
you look at James Harden and you know
the white hours sold two very
interesting organizations that's going
on I think in the right direction so it
would be a pleasure to interview with
them and see where they go Byron always
great to talk to you i wish you well and
thanks for joining us then always a
pleasure anytime that's a Byron Scott
former Lakers head coach the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience